the mayor of Puerto Rico's capital city
is blasting the federal response to the
aftermath of Hurricane Maria Maria
crippled the island when it made
landfall 10 days ago most of Puerto
Rico's 3.4 million residents are without
power half are without running water on
Friday San Juan mayor Carmen you lean
crews accused the Trump administration
of inefficiency in delivering aid to the
island this morning the president hit
back on Twitter writing the mayor of San
Juan who was very complimentary only a
few days ago has now been told by the
Democrats that you must be nasty to
Trump he continued such poor leadership
ability by the mayor of San Juan and
others in Puerto Rico who are not able
to get their workers to help they want
everything to be done for them when it
should be a community effort 10,000
federal workers now on island doing a
fantastic job the president heads to
Puerto Rico on Tuesday he's spending the
weekend at his New Jersey Golf Club as I
mentioned and as the Washington Post
reports this morning that's also where
the president spent last weekend as well
just days after the damage from
Hurricane Maria was becoming apparent ed
O'Keefe shares a byline on that story
examining the president's initial
response and he joins us from our
Washington bureau ed good morning good
to see you guys and the post writes that
that initially the White House seemed to
be on top of things but then four days
after it the storm made landfall as you
write Trump and his top aides
effectively went dark themselves what
happened exactly well let's remember
that it was last weekend when the
President on Friday went down to Alabama
to do a campaign rally for senator
Luthor strange who ended up losing a
primary on Tuesday and then he spent
most of the weekend at least via Twitter
concerned about North Korea and whether
or not NFL players are taking a knee
during the national anthem based on our
reporting it looks like the president
was getting very little information
about what was happening in Puerto Rico
there were not high level conversations
between him and officials on the island
or representing the island and it wasn't
until Monday when the FEMA administrator
and his homeland security adviser when
down to the island to inspect things for
themselves and then return to Washington
on Tuesday that the administration
really seemed to kick into high gear and
realize that much more needed to be done
so ed was it really during that time
that you're talking about over the
weekend and into now Monday Tuesday
before anyone realized how dire things
were in Washington to some extent yes
but that was also partly because Island
officials were still trying to start out
how bad it was remember they had been
cut off from most of the island they
hadn't heard from local mayor's they
hadn't been able to go out and survey
the damage but by Sunday it was apparent
that the situation was dire I think what
we've got here is a combination of an
administration that was talking pretty
closely and frequently with officials on
the island but who collectively here in
Washington and in San Juan weren't able
to fully assess the situation for a few
days and then once it became apparent
that there was a bigger problem on the
island it took the White House until
Tuesday really to start kicking in the
high gear and almost from the beginning
the mayor of San Juan has literally been
begging for help we heard her again
yesterday we heard the president's
response this morning how effective do
you think that's going to be well it you
know frankly I'm not surprised because
you know that the president lashes out
at people who criticize him one point of
clarification with her she's a member of
the popular Democratic Party Puerto Rico
does its political parties a little
differently mostly around the issue of
status whether or not Puerto Rico should
be an independent country a state or
continue in its current status that
party that she's a member of is loosely
associated with the Democratic Party on
the mainland but she herself is not a
full-blown Democrat the criticism she's
been expressing quite publicly from the
capital is similar to what we've been
hearing from small town mayors across
the island there's frustration that the
central government they're led by the
governor isn't necessarily being
responsive when I talked to him
yesterday I asked him about this I said
we're hearing from a lot of the mayor's
who are frustrated about this he says
look I understand it's their job to be
worried about their constituents we're
doing what we can to get supplies into
their hands to make sure that the
situation in their towns is being
addressed and he said in the coming days
as these as he kept saying boots on the
ground arrived to provide assistance the
situation should have
proved dramatically will see we will ed
O'Keefe in our Washington bureau this
morning and thank you